we've all had daydreams about being able
to fly
we can't defy the laws of physics but we
can still dream about it so what does it
mean when a character in a film gets to
fly let's look at a classic example in
ET the adults of the community showing
conformity hostility to anything new
xenophobia suspicion and a lack of
imagination are bearing down on our
young heroes they've even set up a
roadblock at just the moment when things
look worse - the bicycles leave the
earth and with it the earthbound
grownups we see escape wonder magic and
freedom through flight flying is freedom
let's do some closer readings of flying
in film Jenny and Forrest Gump wants to
be free she wants to fly away from her
troubles she has a sexually abusive
alcoholic father she prays to fly away
from him but does she get her wings kind
of the police do take her to her
grandmother so she's technically free
from her father but this camera shot
tells a different story the camera moves
up into the sky and birds fly away with
us but Jenny stays put on the ground in
a literal sense she does get freed from
her father but figuratively she's still
stuck she can't fly away from the
emotional damage her father caused look
at the shot of her as an adult still
falling to the ground at the sight of
her old house the camera shot is placed
firmly at ground level reflecting that
she's still grounded she failed to free
herself from the shackles of her past
throughout the movie we see her trying
to fly away and fail each time he's a
guy who flies this bridge the close-up
on her shoes shows Jenny trying to leap
out of them but she can't she's stuck
later she tries using drugs to forget
her abuse and fly away the song free
bird playing in the background during
this scene is definitely no coincidence
now when she wants to fly she's higher
up in a building and wearing high heels
but no matter how much she tries
extending herself upwards she still
slips and faces the reality that she
can't fly she can't escape the scars of
her childhood
only when Jenny goes back home to forest
does she start to emotionally recover
nobody can fly away from their past but
we can confront it accept and move on
she dies but she doesn't die alone or
trapped she dies in the company of
people she loves and that's when she
truly becomes free like a bird
sometimes in film the character does
feel like they're flying we can see
parallels between Jenny's attempted
flight and Rosa's flight in Titanic in
the beginning suicide off the back of
the Titanic seems to be the only chance
of escape Rose has from her rich plain
lifestyle and unwanted marriage with
Jack however she can now embrace a
newfound beauty in her life at the front
of the boat look at the difference
between these static dark close-ups on
the back of the ship and the sweeping
shots of color in the later scene we
perceive some innate Beauty to the idea
of flying that's reflected in Titanic
Birdman has such an interesting
portrayal of flight because in the film
our hero Regan Thompson rejects flight
he chooses to stay on the ground and
perform his play and Birdman flight is
still a symbol of freedom but it's a
freedom riggan wants to avoid riggan
wants to stay grounded in face reality
his play seeks to comment on the issues
of being human with flight a person
escapes the struggles of being human
so flight means we no longer need the
philosophical discussions on being human
because we've escaped the need for them
riggan wants to stay on the ground
because he wants to make art that
actually mean something if he flies and
make superficial superhero movies he'll
be unable to make any profound
commentary on the human condition
because through flight he has escaped
the human condition he stays on the
ground so he can comment on the
struggles of being grounded in his play
so what about the flight at the end of
the film I think this is a different
kind of flight mainly because it's not
just him that sees it his daughter does
by this time in the film riggan has
overcome the need to please others he
does his play and does what he wants
purely for himself he transcended our
needs as humans to fit in and please
others and we see this transcendence
represented through flight he achieved a
higher sense of being both literally and
symbolically so maybe we can't defy the
laws of physics and fly but if you
manage to figure out yourself and your
place in the universe it sure feels like
this isn't fine
this is falling with style
thanks for watching